ich kann nicht schlafen wegen meinem
pony hallo leute hier seht ihr mal waren
und willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute geht es um das thema schlafen hey
wie gehts dir schläft in letzter zeit
auch nicht so gut dafür bin ich da und
um es genau zu sagen geht es nicht um
das thema schlafen sondern einschlafen
wie schnell wie schnell könnt ihr
einschlafen und wie können wir das
einschlafen verbessern
darum geht es heute ich persönlich würde
schon sagen dass ich ein schlafprobleme
habe besonders wenn ich meinen freund
timo daneben sehe der wirklich jeden tag
perfekt um 11 uhr anfängt müde zu werden
und dann zehn minuten später auch ein
arzt ob wir gerade fernseher schauen im
bett liegen
[Musik]
er kann halt immer einschlafen und daran
merke ich dass ich irgendwie probleme
damit haben und sind wir mal ehrlich die
folgen von coop 19 erschwert glaube ich
viel gerade das einschlafen das macht es
nicht besser das hat auch gleich mehrere
gründe der schlafrhythmus wurde durch
homeschooling und home offices komplett
durcheinander geworfen menschen gehen
weniger raus und bekommt dadurch weniger
sonne ab und alleine die psychische
belastung die durch corona entstanden
ist bringt halt viele darum friedlich
einzuschlafen auch dass eine kombination
aus allem und am ende leidet die psyche
drunter und jetzt im sommer gerade bei
der hitze kann man vielleicht auch noch
schlechter schlafen also der perfekte
zeitpunkt um über das thema zu sprechen
kommt um mich bei dieser ganzen sache zu
unterstützen habe ich meinen
gesundheitspartner aok am schlüssel denn
mit dem aktuellen motto gemeinsam widmen
sie sich dem thema mentaler gesundheit
im zeichen von corona und ganz aktuell
dem thema schlaf und bären verbundenen
schlafprobleme dazu werde ich auch noch
ein interview führen und zwar mit einer
schlafexperten ich bin gespannt was sie
mir für tipps geben kann
bis dahin möchte ich aber ein paar
einschlag tipps seine ausprobieren dazu
habe ich euch auch auf instagram gefragt
und ihr hattet sehr viele einschlaf
tipps gestern war tag 1 und ich habe das
klassische schiff in vielen ausprobiert
[Musik]
dritten mal liebe sagen ich im fond
lange gebraucht um gestern erst richtig
einschlafen zu können ich glaube ich war
echt lange wach noch schiff ins team
funktioniert bei mir überhaupt nicht
dann haben wir noch viele gesagt das
hörbuch hören zum einschlafen helfen
soll
das problem ist ich finde hörbücher
immer viel zu spannend und schlafe
besonders schlecht ein wenn ich etwas
höheren auch klassiker dabei wie milch
mit honig rasse mehr videos schauen
dieser typ gefällt mir ganz besonders
gut t shirts auf wort gab
hier braucht jemand vier stunden zum
einschlafen ohg meine community hat
dieses video gebraucht ich habe einen
mythos im internet gefunden und zwar
soll sport vor dem schlafen helfen
deswegen werde ich heute abend eine
runde joggen gehen durch auch noch nie
gemacht und dann eiskalt duschen soll
helfen ich habe jetzt schon keinen bock
mehr so es ist 22 uhr 10 und ich bin
noch nicht müde aber jetzt geht's ans
jacket
[Musik]
ich habe mich heute gern ich fühle mich
gerade wie so ein tier was ihn
rausgelassen hat er zum käfig also ich
fühle mich jetzt schon das einzige was
mir jetzt noch im weg steht ist kalt
duschen einfach spaß mich leiden zu
sehen was soll ich sagen ich hab' kalt
geduscht reifer und sehen wird nicht
wieder
[Musik]
nicht wollen dann über die andere
kulisse ich drehe gerade meine
produktion armee torte die ihr
wahrscheinlich schon gesehen und dachte
drei fliegen eine klatsche mein fazit
zum joggen und eiskalt duschen ist auf
jeden fall positiver als gedacht auf der
pro seite steht das erschöpft war und
meinen kopf frei kriegen konnte von dem
ganzen alltag auf der contra seite waren
auf jeden fall die nassen haare wie man
hätte lange noch trocken füllen müssen
und wenn ich auf der couch geblieben
wäre wäre ich glaube ich schneller in so
einen gemütlichen modus gekommen und
hätte dann mich einfach irgendwann
schlafen gelegt aber dann hätte ich
vielleicht auch nicht so abschalten
können wie beim joggen also sehr
ausgewogen das ergebnis kommen wir daher
zum mythos nummer 3 und zwar als manch
einer denkt alkohol hilft beim
einschlafen dazu möchte ich aber ganz
besonders doll betonen dass alkohol für
nichts eine lösung ist das heißt wenn
ihre schlafprobleme habt
einschlafprobleme bitte nicht denken das
eigenhaar schlaf problem lösen kann oder
irgendwelche anderen probleme merkte ich
dass ich möchte jetzt nur just for fun
wissen ob ich mit ein bisschen alkohol
im blut schneller einschlafen kann
das heißt jetzt nicht dass ich mir die
kante geben nur aber so ein typisches
glas wein also von den eltern kennt zwar
liegen sind sagen wir machen und so
schön konkreten guten alten gin tonic da
macht man nichts falsch
[Musik]
irgendwann sirup barbara ski logischen
hat man ja auch alles so casual zu hause
liegen erklärt ist vielleicht nicht der
ganze krieg nicht jemals gemacht habe
aber post was soll ich euch noch weiter
dazu zeigen jetzt ein rein zimmern
[Musik]
ich habe so eine leichte koreanische
röte im gesicht wie sie getrunken hat ja
zwei gläsern getrunken und ja ich bin
gut angetrunken muss man sagen bin ich
müde sehr müde und ich werde ins bett
gehen wie spät es ist
von der urzeit her ist es eigentlich
super ich bin selten um diese uhrzeit
schon so müde wie ich jetzt bin also
kann man schon sagen ich bin müde
gute nacht alkohol ist kein akutes
aufstehen
[Musik]
mein name ist siegfried linne ich bin
diplom psychologin logische
tiertherapeutin und eben sonder loren
und sammler lage ist sozusagen ein
schlafexperte dass es bei den ärzten der
schlafmediziner ist bei den psychologen
zum logo ich würde dann gleich mit
meinen es spezifischen fragen anfangen
das okay ist und war thema essen vorm
schlafengehen
ich habe das gefühl wenn ich mittags
eine große portion essen das ich dann
sehr müde werde und schnell einschlafen
kann man sagt ja aber vorm schüler also
vom richtigen abend schlaf sollte man
nicht essen warum das wenn man jetzt
ziel ist das macht erst mal müde das
macht sogar so müde dass es dafür ein
fachbegriff gibt das heißt post brachial
also müdigkeit nach dem essen schlafen
höchst aktiver prozess im leben ganz
viel passiert und aufeinander abgestimmt
sein muss und wenn man jetzt zwei
prozesse hat die internen laufen dann
stören die sich gegenseitig warum wird
sich corona oder die ganze corona
situation gerade negativ auf dem schlaf
also aus wo wo es die verbindung
dazwischen war ja also das deshalb jetzt
psychologisch gesehen wenig mit corona
und wenig mit schlaf sozusagen zu tun
sondern der hintergrund ist der weniger
probleme hat dann ist das problem
eigentlich nicht das problem sondern die
fehlende lösung strecken und das wirkt
sich natürlich auch auf den schlaf aus
wenn ich nicht techniken hat mit denen
ich egal was in meinem leben gerade
passiert oder jetzt in diesem fall mit
corona im leben von allen mit denen ich
sozusagen innere distanz schaffen kann
und mir abend klammern kann so jetzt bin
ich hier in einem geschützten raum und
egal wie sehr ich jetzt hier probleme
hin und her wälzt ich werde es nicht
lösen ich lass das jetzt ruhen und
beschäftige ich morgen wieder damit aber
jetzt steht meine körperliche erholungen
fordert gibt es eine methode oder gibt
es eine art herauszufinden dass ich
einfach schlechter ein schläfer bin oder
da wirklich ein problem da steckt diese
definitionen sind natürlich ein bisschen
schwammig aber rein
die man gut greifen kann ist es dass es
mehr als zwei bis dreimal die woche über
einen zeitraum von mindestens vier
wochen auftritt also ich hab jetzt schon
drei tage einschlafen getestet nummer
eins war schäfchen zählen das hat aus
meiner erfahrung so sehr gut
funktioniert alles was mit zahlen zu tun
hat läuft halt über das frontal ian und
deswegen ist das ungünstig weil das von
dahlien eigentlich eher entspannt sein
soll zum einschlafen und am tag und
relativ spät raus gegangen
joggen und habe danach eine eiskalte
dusche genommen also der kalte dusche
ist schon tendenziell aktivieren
es gibt menschen die nutzen das dann
auch sei technisch so mit mit einer
imagination szene kombiniert ich weiß
jetzt alles von diesem tag von mir ab
und zack bumm dusche und weg ist und
also die idee sport zu machen aber es
ist schon mal prinzipiell die gute aber
es sollte genügend pausen seile zum
gewünschten einschlaf zeitpunkt und
gestern nacht habe ich eine dritten
dritten ein schlafmittel eingeholt ja
also ist keine geeignete einschlafhilfe
auf dauer und zwar meine ich das
wirklich jetzt nicht so mit dem
erhobenen zeigefinger irgendwie sondern
einfach wissenschaftlich alkohol ist ein
muskelrelaxans das heißt es entspannt
tendenziell und das hilft natürlich beim
einschlafen aber es macht eben auch in
deutschland störung weil das thema
rezeptoren gibt im blut die das dann
verarbeiten für beck reaktionen sagen
schlaf schneller ein ich schlafe
schlecht da durch und ich habe eben
diese suchtpotenzial wenn ich regelmäßig
zur selbstmedikation benutze dann werde
ich die dosis sehr schnell immer mehr
erhöhen müssen den effekt nicht
erreichen
aus meiner sicht eine der wichtigsten
sachen ist das auch wenn man hier beim
schlaf nicht beim war im wach-
bewusstsein ist dass man trotzdem sich
eine umgebung schafft in der man sich
wohlfühlt und auch die entspannungs
fähig ist als zweiter würde ich auf
jeden fall nicht mit verschiedenen
entspannungstechniken beschäftigen und
versuchen etwas zu finden was ich was
mir gefällt und das regelmäßig
trainieren so dass ich abends mit
technik hat mit der ich bewusst
herunterfahren und dieses umschalten von
bach funktionieren spannend kontrolle
abgeben
ganz bewusst gestaltet ein ritual
erschaffen okay ein dritter tipp ist
dass wenn es eben so ist dass ich über
einen längeren zeitraum probleme mit dem
ein- und durchschlafen oder mangelnder
schlaf erholsam kite hat dass ich dann
nämlich allzu lange warten bevor ich auf
konstruktive weise damit
auseinandersetzen
die informationen holen das ist ein
wenig ein onlinekurs macht oder daneben
wenn es überhaupt besser wird mir dann
auch wirklich fachlichen die ziele
schrägstrich psychologische
unterstützung zu denn je länger ich
warte umso länger wird es dauern das in
griff zu kriegen was ist ihre meinung zu
asien eher eine form der wirkung ist
einfach das rituelle und das andere ist
dass es zusätzlich ja nichts anderes ist
als letztendlich über eine mischung aus
dem körperlichen psychischen zugang eine
entspannung herzustellen ja das was
glaube ich von mir ich habe keine ahnung
mehr alles abgeklappert dankeschön
danke auch dafür dass ich so selten
interviews führe und ich mega aufgeregt
war davor was ich sagen das ist super
interessant ist auch mal mit einer
expertin oder einem experten über
bestimmte themen zu sprechen um nochmal
die tipps zusammenzufassen nummer eins
eine angenehme schlafumgebung der name
schlafzimmer sagt es doch eigentlich
schon hier wird
geschlafen das bedeutet alles was dich
von deinem erholsamen schlaf ablenken
kann will dich ablenken dass keine
unfertigen aufgaben vom alltag liegen
räumen das schlafzimmer auf denn auch
wenn du mit deinen geschlossenen augen
da liegst spürt dein körper die
anwesenheit einer dreckigen socken und
wenn man jetzt in einer wg oder zu hause
bei seinen eltern wohnt dann findet
alles in einem zimmer statt das ist
natürlich nicht so leicht erst
schlafzimmer zu nennen aber hier könnte
man zum beispiel durch tücher trennwände
oder regale den schlafbereich einfach
optisch abtrennen so dass man besser zur
ruhe kommt tipp nummer zwei schlaf
rituale sind wichtig läufe die abends
stattfinden und somit seinem körper das
signal geben
gleich geht es ins bett bringen den
körper einfach schneller dazu in diesen
schlafmodus zufall dass können
tagebücher sein die hier abends schreibt
räucherkerzen die euch nochmal an macht
eine meditation regelmäßig am abend die
euch runter bringen oder was auch immer
eure kreativität rausbringt hauptsache
ihr wiederholtes am abend so dass euer
körper wirklich masse memory macht hans
mahr film mr ihn endlich ich glaube
schon
tipp nummer drei erkennen und
recherchieren dass man vielleicht an
einem schlafproblemen leidet und dem
sich auch mal zuwendet den schlaf ist
sehr wichtig und wenn man nicht zu einem
guten schlaf kommt sollte man das nicht
einfach auf die leichte schulter nehmen
das ist wie mit den handys wenn man sie
immer nur halb auflädt gehen die akkus
schneller kaputt bestes beispiel und was
ich aus dem interview am meisten
mitgenommen habe ist definitiv das ist
sehr wichtig ist zu lernen denn hier und
jetzt zu sein viel zu oft ist man mit
den gedanken
und das ist furchtbar und besonders wenn
man ein schlafen möchte und merkt dass
man mit den gedanken viel zu viele
wander dann kommt man auch viel
schneller dieses gefühl von ah ich
sollte ist eingeschlafen
warum kann die strafe gegen frühere auf
und es ist wichtig das zu üben dass man
seine aufmerksamkeit im hier und jetzt
behält und zum beispiel durch atmung
einfach hier bleibt also auch seine
atmung zu achten ist das beste was man
eigentlich machen kann und wichtig ist
dass man nicht dann wenn man eh schon
angespannt ist und dass einem die decke
auf den kopf fällt sondern täglich auch
wenn es einem gut geht ist es wieder so
ein neues instrument lernt oder
irgendeinen sport lernst du gehst ja
nicht zu deiner ersten stunde und kannst
es und auch nicht bei der zweiten und
dritten das braucht ein bisschen übung
und wenn du es dann irgendwann gelernt
hast dann kannst es also in dieser
komplizierten zeit in der wir uns gerade
befinden in der keiner so richtig weiß
wie es weitergeht wie sich die pandemie
noch entwickeln wird was für folgen das
haben wird ist es umso wichtiger dass
ihr bei euch bleibt und eure mitte
findet also atmet mit mir einmal ganz
tief durch und alles raus
wir werden das alle gemeinsam
durchstehen es wird noch weiterer
content zu diesem thema folgen worauf
ich mich sehr freue übrigens auch auf
meine nase mehrkanal und auf dem balkan
falls ihr erfahrungen zum thema
einschlafen gut schlafen habt schreibt
sie mir gerne gerne in die kommentare
besonders eure einschlaf tipps würde
mich mal interessieren übrigens gibt es
noch was von meinem gesundheitspartner
aok zu gewinnen alle infos dazu findet
ihr im ersten link in der video
beschreibung viel glück und viel spaß
dabei und wir sehen uns das nächste mal
wieder biss dann alle schlafen